MARTIN OMANDER: Hi, Guillaume.
I heard you help companies
move to the cloud.
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: Hi, Martin.
Yes, I work for Accenture.
We're [INAUDIBLE] company.
We help businesses move to the
cloud, including serverless.
I have helped many
businesses make the move.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Could you tell us what you've
learned about successful cloud
migrations?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: Yeah.
I would be happy to.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARTIN OMANDER: All right.
So in your experience,
what kind of businesses
want to move to the cloud?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Oh, most of them.
They don't want to buy more
servers for their data centers.
Servers in the cloud are cheaper
when you take into account
all the management costs--
plugs in servers, unplug
this one, destroy the disk,
ensure the site
physical security.
[INAUDIBLE] has released a great
video on the Google Cloud data
center security, and it's
harder than you think.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yeah.
That's a really good video.
You know, I remember
putting servers
into racks for one of my
startups back in the day.
Our data center was in
San Mateo, California.
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Yeah, that's fine.
But you may need one data
center in Europe, one in Asia,
one in North America, and so on.
Loads of data storage
may force you to do that.
Or you may want your
servers close to your users
to reduce latency.
This means it's
hard to go global.
With Cloud, you
get that for free.
But there are true challenges.
In my experience, when a
business migrate to the cloud,
they face three
major challenges.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, what
are those three challenges?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
First of all, security.
The security teams in most
businesses want to make sure
that their internal system
cannot be accessed from
the internet.
That's usually how they're
existing on-prem [INAUDIBLE]
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
that sounds reasonable.
How do you help them with that?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: Two things.
First, I like to remove the
virtual machines to VPCs
and to put all the VMs
be on load balancers.
So the VMs are not directly
visible to the [INAUDIBLE]
internet.
Second, I help them set
up oganization policies.
This means that new VMs
cannot get [INAUDIBLE] without
an exception to the policy.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
So that's for virtual machines.
What about security
for serverless?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Serverless is a new [INAUDIBLE]
Many serverless products
have [INAUDIBLE] by default,
so they base their security
on cloud [INAUDIBLE]..
And many security teams are
uncomfortable with that.
MARTIN OMANDER: And how
do you deal with that?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: Oh, I
explain this to [INAUDIBLE]
and how we can help them
implement zero-trust.
This means that we don't
trust incoming traffic
just because it's from
your internal network.
You check all traffic
and trust the identity
in [INAUDIBLE] of the origin.
MARTIN OMANDER: So you said
there were three challenges.
What's the second one?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: The
second is cost uncertainty.
It's hard to estimate how
much your cloud system will
cost when exposed to [INAUDIBLE]
workload and traffic.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yeah, I've
heard that from developers too.
And what's your solution?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: I tell our
customers set up [INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] with
a cost calculator.
That way, they get an
email if [INAUDIBLE] bill
goes above a certain threshold.
However, many of my customer
have gone serverless.
That's magic for them,
that scale up and down
automatically.
But they're also the feeling
of losing control of cost.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, and
what can be done about that?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
In general, you
can set the maximum
number of instances.
So, for example,
[INAUDIBLE],, they
will never pay for more than
10 [INAUDIBLE] instances.
And they can put these
limits on several
of their serverless
products, like data flow or
[? bitcoin. ?]
MARTIN OMANDER: Got it.
And what's the third
challenge you've
seen businesses run into when
they migrate to the cloud?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: Yeah,
this other one is trust.
Everyone-- as a customer, I have
to trust the cloud provider.
It's easy when your system
are in your own data centers.
You trust your own
servers, [INAUDIBLE],,
monitoring systems, and
when you know the teams
in charge of your data centers.
MARTIN OMANDER: And how do you
address that trust challenge?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: Businesses
have to ask the same thing.
Can my cloud provider
[INAUDIBLE] server better
than I can, or as well
as me, but for less?
MARTIN OMANDER: Yeah,
that's why businesses
want to move to the cloud
in the first place, right?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Right, right.
Smart companies want to
delegate IT to a cloud provider,
to save money and to
be more efficient.
They want to focus their
teams and money on their core
business, but it takes
time to gain trust.
And it's not a matter of company
size or move to cloud budgets.
It depends more on
how old the system is.
The older it is,
the harder it will
be to gain confidence
in the cloud.
One good way is to
run a pilot project
to migrate one small
noncritical system to the cloud.
MARTIN OMANDER: And
when your customers
run these pilot projects,
how does it usually work out?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: [CHUCKLES]
In fact, most of them
want to be cloud
native, to use only
managed and serviced
products, or to use
containers and Kubernetes.
However, it's a big
step to train the teams
in serverless or Kubernetes.
You need many small
steps before that,
like setting up
your CI/CD pipeline
and putting your
applications in containers.
MARTIN OMANDER: CI/CD
pipelines and containers--
those are big topics.
How can they get started?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE: I tell them
to start by performing a lift
and shift migration.
Move one of their existing
application, as is,
to the cloud.
As they do that, they learn
what's works well in the cloud.
And they are in a better
place with an existing app
to set up CI/CD and modernize
with serverless or Kubernetes.
MARTIN OMANDER:
And why should they
start using CI/CD and
serverless or Kubernetes?
GUILLAUME BLAQUIERE:
Oh, they can
shift code faster,
reduce so many errors,
and optimize costs.
[INAUDIBLE] and the
Google Cloud white paper
describe the return
on investment
of DevOps transformation
and how to do it.
Have a look at it.
MARTIN OMANDER: Sounds good.
Thanks, for sharing your
hard-won experience with us
today, Guillaume.
If you have any questions
for Guillaume or me,
please enter them in
the comments below.
Also, please let
me know if there
are any other topics you'd like
us to bring up on the show.
Until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]